good morning so I am so delighted to
have stephen wolfram here you know it's
one of the great things about my job is
you know over the years I've been able
to follow a lot of terrific people and
one of my favorite and I'm falling from
quite a while is Stephen here and
there's always a fantastic to check in
with him because he's always doing
something amazing he's always ahead of
the curve there so please welcome
Stephen now we're going to talk about
among other things up you know health
technology personal analytics but before
we do that Stephen you know in case you
don't know which batiment is just done
among other things three really big
significant things one is a mathematica
the software platform a company CEO of
another is a groundbreaking book called
a new kind of science which is
self-descriptive and unica third is
Wolfram Alpha and you know to me the
glue of all these things is a sense the
the universe can be computed and that
through computation we could understand
the universe and and ourselves maybe he
never did you want to before we get into
the specifics just say something about
that is you know as a backdrop to what
we'll talk about yeah I mean I guess
I've spent the most of my adult life
kind of trying to take seriously this
idea of computation I mean I'm kind of
I'm kind of convinced that if you look
at the history of the last century or so
the the sort of single most important
thing that's emerged is this idea of
computation and we kind of know this as
a practical matter you know we have
computers computers are doing all kinds
of things in our world but i think this
sort of fundamental concept of
computation were only just started
to see kind of the significance of that
idea and this is about questions like
imagine all possible computer programs
what's this universe what's this
computational universe of possible
programs what do they all do are they
the kinds of things that are going on
for example in biology or in physics for
that matter what when we look at kind of
the knowledge that exists in the world
how much of it can be made computable
that's what I've been interested in with
Wolfram Alpha trying to take kind of all
the knowledge that our civilization has
accumulated and trying to set it up so
that if there's a question that can be
answered on the basis of that knowledge
it becomes automatic to be able to
answer that question by using
computation so I think I think in the
and I'm also kind of suspect that the
way that sort of technology is going to
evolve what we do today where we have
engineers try to actually invent
technology sort of step by step as
humans that's going to be the minority
thing that happens the majority thing
that happens will be more kind of
searching this computational universe of
possibilities making use of sort of all
the things that become possible through
computation so I think this is we sort
of just in the very early stages of
seeing what happens with us okay and
speaking of exploring you know the
computational you know you know results
with stuff that we generate there
recently you've posted some amazing blog
posts about your personnel analytics not
sort of leitmotif of this conference
here I think at one point you claimed
you were the most data collected human
on the planet here Munich and that is my
little bike through all yeah I know you
told like say that I'm hoping that yeah
right no I to talk a little bit about
your personal you know analytics here
well so you know I'm a I'm a data
oriented guy and so I kind of have just
sort of routinely collected lots of data
about myself mostly a nice buddy can
show you this works we can might be able
to even show you something let's see see
what we can find here
not so I have to do this live on an
actual computer because otherwise it's
no fun at all but whilst even walk from
you banging way of a computer yes yes
yes that's what I do that's what I
that's what I spent my life doing and
will learn Yeah right so you know that
this is this is sort of some basic piece
of data this is a dot for every piece of
email that I sent in the last 23 years
so there so what's about that you know
their shift in 2002 what does that mean
that was me finishing my 10 and a half
year effort on my book a new kind of
science mm-hmm uui I saw you right at
the time when that shift was happening
and you mediate I stopped sending emails
no that was that was the big white part
is when I was asleep and not sending
email the but you know you learn so so I
learnt that I went very nocturnal when I
was deep in working on this basic
science project you know you can learn
all kinds of things you know I've learnt
them all sorts of things about oh I
don't know that's key strokes that I've
typed on my computer recorded those for
a long time and you can kind of get a
little bit of somewhere here yeah
there's the kind of thumb there's my my
daily rhythm as a function of time of
day so you see you know there's some
outgoing email distribution I'm probably
most productive late at night I'm not at
all productive not really properly awake
usually at this time of the morning so
we're a blip on the screen yeah that's
right but this will show up a little
blip and it will probably have some some
little tale of higher or lower
productivity I'll find out the bottom I
mean this thing of a bottom of steps
what are you yeah it's just measured
from a digital pedometer I've been doing
that for a few years that's um that's me
trying to you know very habitually take
a certain amount of exercise every every
day I'm at a midnight right no no that's
that's who that dude I got new drug say
yes first thing in the day oh so right
after this you're going to start bombing
up and and and I should yeah yes yeah
and to wrap up the analytics thing you
you also did one about Facebook use what
led you to do that to help people
analyze their Facebook activity and I'm
just curious for the feedback you've got
know what people like I mean so you know
the thing that this this kind of thing
of you know i've been i've been keeping
all the state about myself for a long
time I I as a practical matter while
I've been doing it the the main thing
that I found particularly useful is just
having my computer send me email the day
after telling me you know you type this
number of key strokes or you walk this
distance or whatever else and that's
been a useful way for me to kind of keep
my life organized I suppose for me the
probably the number one issue is I work
on this very large projects they involve
lots of other people they their
never-ending project something like
mathematica i started at 26 years ago
now and it's still growing and and
prospering today and one of the
challenges for somebody like me is to
get completely you know submerged by
large projects that one has already done
and never to be able to do anything new
and so my sort of main mechanism for for
trying to do new things is sort of keep
as organized as possible in what I what
I try to do and that's that's how i came
to sort of collect all this data and so
on but most people have not can't go
back in a you know one can't go back in
a time machine and start collecting this
data and the systems are not not super
easy to set up no more i would think
they we're in that state their you know
their people do more and more things
that are measured yes this is true and
you know one place where people are
leaving sort of a digital Engram of
themselves as in things like Facebook
and so we wanted to see what would
happen if if we just connect we just
sort of you know take people's facebook
data and and try and analyze it so
without with Martha system we've been
particularly concentrating on sort of
ingesting public knowledge in the world
but one of the one of the newer
activities with wolfram alpha is letting
people upload data of their own whether
it's kind of numerical textual data or
whether it's image data whatever else
one form of data that they can now
upload is connecting to the Facebook API
and uploading their facebook data so my
particular facebook account is kind of
boring because I really don't pay any
attention to facebook but you can you
can you can see a few things here I mean
you can see things about people who
commented on post of mine things like
that someplace down here you might be
able to see let's see oh you know
genders of friends age distribution of
my friends together with some people who
I don't believe it really 107 years old
but that's what that's what they tell
Facebook you know there's the geographic
distribution there are things about some
look at that people's birthdays Larry
smart birthday today interesting the RAM
you know who the most common first names
are in things and then this is the the
kind of the social graph mine honestly
is pretty boring and just shows it shows
that pretty much very few of the people
who friended me know each other because
they're all kind of just people out
there in the world for other people
these kinds of graphs tend to tell
pretty interesting stories and that
there's I know this is some just a
smaller graph for me where you can see a
few clusters starting to develop and
people you know people seem to tell us
every time I sort of talk to somebody
about this they look at this and they
look at it for you know for 15 minutes
or something and they start saying well
that's the group of people that I knew
what this you know in high school or
that's the good people that were in this
town and so on it tells a story and I
think what would be really interesting
to see is the time series of the
development of these kinds of social
graphs which I think will tell one quite
a bit about sort of how one is
developing socially so to speak perhaps
you know my gosh I'm getting really
depressed i'm closing in you know my
whole network all these kinds of things
can you use wolfram alpha a sort of a
nexus where you can get multiple feeds
in from you not only from facebook
twitter at social networks but mix it
with all other sorts of information so
you want Wolfram Alpha to be sort of our
go-to point for our analytical analysis
that's the idea I mean one of the things
that that's pretty interesting is being
able to
kind of your personal data with general
public knowledge about the world so you
know being able to know I don't know
whether it knows it for me but but if I
was younger it would probably be able to
tell me what the you know what the
weather was like the day I was born and
you know all these kinds of things that
make use of sort of public public
information in the world and I think
that's some sort of our goal in general
is to have the sort of connections hub
that allows one to take data from you
know API sensors all kinds of things
like this we're sort of we're lucky and
that mathematical gets used by sort of a
decent swath of the world's are in d
fokin we've sort of been forced to
support all these hundreds of different
data formats for all kinds of things so
so it's kind of free for us to be able
to ingest all kinds of data and be able
to analyze it and so on okay so one
thing I know we want to talk about you
want to talk about today is a diagnosis
there you know and how this technology
might radically change the way our
ailments or diagnose their do you want
to talk about that yeah so I mean we
think it's some that's the sort of a
question of you know as you try and
automate things I've spent lots of my
life trying to automate different kinds
of activities and and trying to make
them computational so to speak medical
diagnosis is pretty hard for humans it's
not obvious that it's really should be
that hard for for computers the question
is how come one set about dealing with
that kind of thing well you know mum
alpha we have all sorts of public health
data you know if you type in something
like you know HDL male age you know 48
or something you'll it'll it'll just be
slicing down some public health data and
showing us you know the distribution for
44 people in that that gender & age and
so on we could we could go and we could
start asking it questions about you know
I don't know let's say sore throat plus
cough or something see what see what it
says here and they'll probably be able
to tell us some it
recognizes those are symptoms good sign
and now it will use some public health
database to try and say well how many
people per year have have presented
themselves to doctors with those with
those characteristics how does that vary
with with age things like this this is
all fairly basic and I don't think yet
all that useful the question is can we
do something much better than this where
we can actually enter sort of symptoms
in an organized way and sort of automate
the process of giving us a diagnosis I
think I think the answer is yes and I
think there are several different
sources that will use for this from sort
of traditional medical diagnosis flow
charts to sort of the the 3 million
papers in the medical literature to the
kinds of data that we're getting from
sensors and so on and you know this
whole question about what happens with
medical diagnosis I think it's
inevitable that the the practice of
medical diagnosis has to change because
right now you know you might say well
you know somebody looks pale today or
something like that but that's something
that in the future it's going to be more
there's this 10 megabyte time series of
you know what the pigmentation of your
skin has been based on some sensor and
then the question is how do you how do
you deal with that how do you reason
with that how do you how do you handle
that how do you get deduction from from
that I think that's something that's
only force sort of the process of
diagnosis to become much more
computational an algorithmic and we're
trying to figure out how how best to do
those kinds of things what is part of
this an integration of sort of an expert
systems approach where you would get
some sort core dump of actual doctors or
things like that or do you think that's
probably too sloppy and you want to you
know I think the only thing look one has
to know what's what's really out there
in the natural world so to speak you
know you've actually got to get large
chunks of medical data analyze them try
and digest from them these kinds of you
know probabilities sequences of things
and so on we've done a certain amount of
work on this and it's actually it's
actually shocking how how good you can
do
well you can do with with really
simplistic kinds of mathematical you've
done some from work without what are you
done won't cover iety of projects were
we're using health care data from from
groups that that we've worked with
typically groups that want custom
versions of both mouth to be built for
their healthcare data and so we've ended
up getting to see some some interesting
fairly large data sets that are not
publicly available and and be able to do
some experiments with them so I've been
doing diagnosing bag Diagnostics with
that have you been diagnosing no not
really I mean that's more just being
able to do things like predict given
that there's been a series of diagnosis
codes that have been seen what will be
seen in the future those kinds of things
um and which is which is not yet the
sort of the fine version of diagnosis
that I think that I think is possible um
I think no go no I mean you know what
one question is is what um you know you
think about medical diagnosis one of the
things about medical diagnosis that's a
loom disappointing in a sense is you
know how does one actually classify
diseases you know there's they're all
these fine you know icd-9 icd-10 all
these all these fine classifications of
diseases but it's a little bit unclear
from a from a basic science point of
view I think a little bit about you know
well how should we really think about
about diseases and you know how to sort
of give an ontology of them and so on
and I've kind of been interested in an
analogy for a human disease which is
what we might call software disease and
you know you think about a computer it's
running it's running its operating
system you know things over over the
course of time sort of crud builds up
and the operating system things get slow
it starts to malfunction in various ways
and eventually splat you know it crashes
it dies then you got to restart it again
sort of from the same genetic material
and then next generation of the you know
the next run of your operating system or
whatever so I've been sort of thinking
about you know how do you diagnose
software problems and and you know
there's no icd-9 icd-10 for software
it's kind of you know there's no kind of
you know Merck Manual with you know
diseases of the display subsystem and so
on that that is a you know that's not
been that's not been created sometimes
tech support groups have had things a
bit like that
but they're very primitive even compared
to human medical diagnosis and so you
know one of the things we've been
interested in actually is the question
of when you look at a large software
system and you see it running what can
you measure about it that's kind of an
indication of its health wait a minutes
like you go measure its blood pressure
or something like this what's the you
know you can you can measure very very
coarse things like memory usage things
like this but the question is you know
with it with a software system you can
actually go in and see every single bit
in the software system and principal
it's much easier than but you know for
human medicine in today's world and you
know what do you measure we don't get
know the answer to this but it's an
interesting sort of sort of thought
experiment one things you realize from
thinking about this is yes you can sort
of put diseases software diseases into
various kinds of buckets but there's a
tremendous fine structure and what's
happening inside these these buckets and
it's not the case that you can sort of
say from the point of view of how you
should treat the thing it's not obvious
that you know the but it may be too big
to be able to specify how to treat it I
think it's the same thing you know you
see in biomedicine people say oh well
there's there's just this one kind of
cell that does such and such a thing
well studied a bit more well actually no
there's there's five different variants
well actually no it's even more
complicated than that and it reminds me
greatly of a lot of basic science that
I've done where where one looks at sort
of all possible programs for things
where one looks at some simple programs
i don't know i've got to kind of bring
up my my all-time favorite probably very
go there insert some the this is this is
a typical example of a very very simple
program that has the feature that if you
run it just starting from a single black
cell it makes it does very complicated
kinds of things if you change the
program just tiny bit it does very
different kinds of things my guess is
that what's happening here is very
similar to what's happening when you see
all these different kinds of immune
system cells or something like that in
the body that each different kind of
cell is effectively running a slightly
different program the the results of
those programs are very different too so
actually that might lead you to
something pessimistic in terms about
treating diseases
air of every disease you know turns out
to get its own level of complexity there
we might find you know these amazing
cures we would hope for to be sort of
elusive well i think that the you know
what what it tells one is you have to be
algorithmic about the whole thing you
have to be able to simulate things you
have to be able to you're not
necessarily going to find this sort of
one global thing it also suggests that
when you start thinking about things
like drugs you know today's drugs tend
to be just you know i find the site i
bind to it i make something happen you
know drugs in the future one can expect
to be much more computational to be
actually little molecular computers but
a computational drug be like it would be
a universal platform just like for
computers and there was a time when
computers you know there was a time
before people understood about Universal
computation when people said I've got an
adding machine no I've got a square root
machine here they're all different
machines and then people realize that it
was possible to make a single Universal
computer that you could just make do all
these different things by pure
programming the same kind of thing I
think it's going to happen for molecules
and it's going to be the case that not
only can you sort of change what the
molecule does you could also have it
make decisions about what to do based on
kind of its environment not unlike what
what biology itself manages to do but
that means that you get to to have a
much greater variation in the types of
types of things that you can do and it
doesn't and then then the question is
well well what should you make this
molecule do how can you actually have
some better outcome for for this some
for this process that's running and so
on and then you have to start thinking
about doing modeling and simulation and
so on well from it from a clinical model
then what do you envision you know are
you know uh diagnosis and treatment to
be like if you extend this vision you
know a decade or two out what's going to
happen how am I going to find out what's
what's wrong with me how am I going to
treat it well I think wonder how much is
going to be me my sensors my computer
and is my doctor a genius bar now I mean
how does that work well I think I think
you know my guess is that people will
sort of watch their health in a way
that's a little toaster to the way that
they watch to the finance
folios and things then whatever might
have arming Yeah right but but you know
so what happens in finance for example
you can say well there are these
symptoms of what's going on with some
stock it has some wiggle that looks like
this you know if you're a technical
trading you say well that wiggle looks
like you know a head and shoulders
effect or something like this and then
you say well given that well I should
buy sell whatever I whatever I should do
you know but in fact we know that in the
finance area it's much more you know
given this particular behavior we have
some algorithm the algorithm decides
what to do and we go on from there my
guess is that instead of the medical
world it will be much more like that
there'll be a lot of sensor data that's
coming in you'll see all these curves
there'll be all sorts of detailed
effects in those curves some of which
you'll be able to describe in some sort
of easy linguistic way others of which
are just well it's a wiggle in the curve
and there's nothing particularly to call
it the the thing that and then what will
happen is there's both a certain amount
of human you know looking at these
curves that will happen just like there
is and you know and financial kinds of
things but there's also potentially lots
of algorithms that you get to use to
decide what to do so I'm guessing it
will be sort of sensors in algorithms to
decide what to do potentially
algorithmic drugs and various kinds of
algorithmically oriented medical devices
actually right so I'm all connected and
I get my diagnosis my makerbot can Cox
me a computational drug and I'm good
well that right so so there's some basic
science to figure out before the full do
that I mean one of one of the things
that's you know one of the things that
came out of the basic science that I
spent a lot of time thinking about is
you know you look at a picture like this
and you say well what will happen a
million steps from now how can you
figure out what's going to happen you
might say you know it's sort of the
traditional science is all about doing
predictions you might say well you know
let's just use science to make a
prediction of what's going to happen
turns out you can show that's not in
general possible as this thing I call
computational irreducibility that makes
one makes it be the case that you know
you kind of there's no way to know
what's going to happen other than
essentially to simulate each step
mutational irreducibility bites us in
understanding things about fundamental
theory of physics and so on I think it's
going to bite us in medicine too and
we're going to end up finding out that
in many cases we we can't sort of
immediately predict what's going to
happen we're going to actually have to
follow through these steps to work it
out and then we're going to have to see
we're going to have to start enumerate
in here are some possible interventions
that we can make what are the effects of
these different interventions and it's
going to be a very sort of computational
process okay great we have time for
maybe just one or one or two questions
here I don't see anything for Twitter
and there's a hands there maybe the mic
can reach you there so thank you very
much very insightful um what about if we
had a tool that would be called a
virtual human and because diagnosis and
treatment this is about big data and in
this virtual room it would be open
source and you would capture retrieve
navigate and visualize all data that
people are posting there and it would be
Google like Google Earth like where you
can zoom in and out and you can post
pictures and there you diagnose so this
is all based on data are put into
context and lead to information and then
to knowledge so what about it project
like this so you could do this with the
NIH together with Google with Wikipedia
medicine so it he might want to do a
bang this is partner for what and so you
know I'm not quite sure what the I mean
you know at the level of sort of the map
of the human actually in wolf's mouth
are very soon there'll be a data that's
derived from the visible human project
and you'll be able to sort of ask
linguistically things like you know what
what bones does this nerve go closest to
and things like that but in terms of
being able to take large amounts of sort
of crowd-sourced data from people about
their medical States and diagnosis and
sensor results and so on yes I fully
expect that they'll be and perhaps
people here are you know are going to
create the great version of this the
sort of a mechanism to you know platform
for for bringing all this kind of data
in you know with Wolf now
and so on what we hope to do is to
provide a good analytics system to sort
of underlie that actually we have a data
repository that we're building primarily
for researchers where people can publish
data that has been set up to be
understandable so to speak data that's
been ingested and put into a forum where
you can actually ask questions from it
and so on okay so one final question I
think so a lot of the conversation has
been around really to focus on the
individual person what tracking or all
of information you tell us from a public
health perspective we think a lot more
about communities populations that there
are external factors that influence your
health as well as all that you know to
your genome and whatnot and so what how
would you use to comment on what the
Wolfram Alpha are all the work that
you're doing sort of how does it sort of
intersect that this public health but
the external as well and can we use
these systems in that genre well I mean
we're you know with wolf Martha we sort
of have coming in I think more more
feeds of data about different kinds of
things that have been sort of
successfully computationally understood
than people have ever had before so
whether it's you know earthquakes or
climate or whatever else is going on we
know lots about the world how one tries
and we don't yet know things like you
know who's getting sick where and what's
you know we only have data from the CDC
and things like that we don't have more
detailed kinds of data it will be very
interesting to be able to get sort of
more crowd-sourced data about those
kinds of things and then to be able to
correlate it with other things that we
know about in the world I think we're in
a good position to do those kinds of
things not something we've we've done
yet clearly also there's you know
there's another dimension which is being
able to capture social network data from
from things like Facebook correlating
that with them with kind of Public
Health kinds of issues this is all very
interesting stuff you know we we look
forward to providing a good platform to
make make things like that possible
great well thank you fascinating as I
hope
you